and a lot of it and for someone who
hasn't gotten on stage yet how how would
you recommend someone goes about it
overcoming that fear
of not bombing well a lot of people a
lot of people listen to the podcast and
they've never been on stage but they
want to but there's X Y and Z reasons
why they haven't
for sure I think just preparation
like the more you prepare the more
you've gone in front of a mirror the
more you've practiced without a group
The more you've said your material to
yourself you know your material you know
what's like
I think that's what helps you
get over that fear if you've never been
on stage but if you're doing stand up
and you've not gone up yet
the work that you do before you actually
go up is just as important the feeling
of bombing obviously is a natural fear
that people aren't going to laugh at you
or people aren't going to
react and that's a part of the process
but if you prepare
before the time rather than you know and
you know there's there's a school of
thought that just that I've heard people
just say yo just go up there and just
stay stuff for five minutes as your
first open mic so then you know what the
feeling's like and then there's a school
of thought that says prepare as much as
possible whatever amount of hours before
you go up I'm probably more in the camp
of prepare as much as possible before
you go up mainly because I think
just going improv saying words and just
thinking that the stuff that's coming
out of your mouth is funny I've tried
that before and that felt terrible
yeah whereas when I when I prepared and
I bombed I didn't bomb all the way
through I bombed at stuff that people
just didn't like but there was just
there's some stuff that was funny
yeah my first time I had like a set and
I rehearsed it relentlessly and I think
what really helped me is I I booked a
date I think once I had a date on the
calendar that it it could be next week
it could be next month but it's like
once I had a date on the calendar then
it's like okay I now have accountability
that on this date I am going to perform
stand up for the first time so now I
need to do as much as possible to
prepare for that set and I think that's
what really helped is having that
deadline
yeah that's a good one I mean I think a
date gets you
a destination
and then if you're committed to it and
you're committed to that date then it's
just what you do beforehand but
definitely yeah I think you know
do yeah set a date I think that's a
that's a really good like just hearty
rule of just setting a goal and going to
go out and meet that goal yeah so
wherever you are Google your city and
like Open Mic or Google your region or
area and open mic and this could be
comedy open mic this could be Music open
mic could be poetry Open Mic I performed
at
um karaoke before
um so just like Google a place where you
can go perform for your first time set
the date set the deadline and then just
prepare as much as possible write out a
set that you think is going to be good
yep rehearse it a lot
Go on stage and check it off your bucket
list
yeah
yeah they said he prepped for eight
months before getting on stage like you
know so yeah I think I wrote for a year
before I got on stage
I wrote for a year and then took a class
and that's when I got on stage but I was
writing what I was interested like ah
maybe I should do this and the stuff I
was writing was like I had no structure
I didn't read anything I was just like
let me just write what I think is funny
and then once I got the class the class
is what helped me get more structure and
figure out joke structures
um and so that that's what helped me for
sure
Kaboom well I hope that helps there fam
hope that helps you there say and you
know we have classes to help you with
that structure of course at
hopperathmedia.com
now
[Music]
[Applause]
and uh we're here for you as well